did it hurt when you fell from the
vending machine because you're such a
snack hi my name is Lauren I'm a
production manager in the entertainment
industry I have a lot of experience with
dating apps I'm on a good amount of them
I'd have been in long-term relationships
obviously I haven't had any long-term
success so I wouldn't be here right now
but you know I'm hopeful gotta keep a
positive spirit
my name's Karina Karina I'm a musician
hi my name is Dana and I work for a tech
company and digital advertising I'm
amber I'm a chef my thoughts on dating
apps is I haven't had the best look so
to me nothing kind of beats organically
meeting someone have you on there
actively pursuing interests but it has
not worked out this far I'll like be
like okay I'm in the mood to text so let
me hey what are you doing but after
you're not doing anything interesting
and I'm like okay let me find something
else my text game is pretty strong you
know you have some some anonymity there
you have a barrier you can take time to
respond I think I have gay I just want
to see my options and hopefully find my
true love hello everyone I'm third wheel
welcome to the group chat first question
describe yourself in three emojis I just
want to see what I would put if I were
to pick three emojis I'm kind of a ham
so definitely a cat because it just
makes it oh unicorn
yeah like an icon to get one okay hearts
is cute you know means I think that's
like she's a lovable person and she
likes cats
I love the cool face I use that a lot
honeypot she likes honey or she likes
sweet things mermaid maybe she like is
into sea life tacos Dana sent a dance
girl mochi love that because I must soon
let me she loves to dance and I love to
dance in a taco which is funny next
question what's your ideal first date in
three emojis I was gonna put like lips
but that may be like too forward
love music food pizza great good girl
doing a handstand that could be sexual I
think I'm gonna put like some outer
space stars we can like look at the
stars that's cute
and we're put oh airplane oh this is
like you're an intense and breakfast
this is definitely means we spent the
night together so we're cooking
breakfast in the morning I'm not mad at
that
okay next one from third wheel send a
picture of your shoes okay this is big
I'm a big sneaker head so like shoes are
a big deal for me oh wow amber has like
a like the fuzzy I don't know it's kind
of cool yeah
Dana's got like a short boot heel on
which I like I really really like Korean
has got these kind of clunkier just got
you're looking kicks I'm gonna send a
picture of my shoes just because I'm
cool
she was Dana's I think Dana sleep kind
of a million is on all of these friends
next question monogamy or something else
oh okay I love Dana and Karina's answers
Amber's was fine but it's clear that you
know maybe she's not looking for
something serious cats or dogs dog all
the way love that Karina said caps I
kind of figured that it's just six cats
oh that's so loud amber said you can't
tame upbeat
facts I think we connected you know I
think that she was really into my jokes
I have no idea how I did I said I have
six cats and not a lot of people like
cats like that I think I did okay some
of my responses were a little awkward I
just I don't know you know I got to make
hard decisions here Sophie's Choice it's
got to be creepy she has six cats I
don't like cats that much oh she's cute
she kind looks like Lady gaga I like her
maybe I made a wrong decision oh I don't
know I'll chat with amber first what are
you looking for in a partner in one
sentence so need to eat my food not
answering my questions
ah I'm the slowest excellent she said so
food because I knew Gabriel said this is
third wheel jumping in what's something
that few people know about you I don't
know I feel that third wheel I didn't
finish answering any more questions that
was so quick now it's Dana's turn
hopefully Dan I'll respond faster feel
like she took a really long time what's
been the hardest part about dating
finding someone who is consistent she
said I have the moves some say like a
young Janet oh you talk a big game
what's your favorite other music dance
anything with a good feet that I can
shake my booty to a hey this is their
real jumping in what would you do if you
want a lottery pay off my student loans
probably save some travel is like like
number one I've won a travel
yes the travelling dream destination we
just asked each other the same question
we're on the same page and then I want
to do the little flags - I think that's
pretty cute that feels like personality
right time is up Lauren you now have
five minutes to make your elimination
and choose your winner who you'll meet
IRL I'm nervous and sweating with Amber
we talked a lot about food she's a chef
which I love we could eat like all day
long I think I think me and Lauren might
actually possibly be a match made in
heaven so Dana I loved what she had to
say about the hardest part about dating
finding someone who's consistent she
also said she's got moves like Janet so
we can get down on dance floor so I'm
totally into that I feel like I did okay
either where I had fun it was a good
time and I met great people I think I
would go with
are you ember it's the dog really cute
it's sad that I have to go I thought we
could have been lovers and friends but
fine your loss
Wow looks like I'm the last one left
this is very exciting I'm still really
nervous though because I have no idea
it's a blind meeting it's a blind date
hi how are you good how are you
morons nice to meet you Lauren so what
is a dancing emoji oh yes is the dancing
emoji I also loved your shoes oh thank
you and you said you could keep up with
me on the dance yeah I totally can what
about your destinations have you been to
Italy I haven't been in Greece I'd love
to go to Greece yeah in Italy maybe you
could show me around
hi rainy mica no going my name is Bob
food wine travel this is like perfect
perfect date yes yeah yeah so what do
you say you want to you want to get out
of here let's get out of here awesome